it makes perfect sense for us to be
eating invasive species because invasive
species are an endless
resource for
food this great big story was made
possible by
[Music]
my name is bun lai i'm the chef at mia's
sushi in new haven 33 years ago my
mother started mia's reimagining sushi
as something that is restorative of the
environment
this is part of the regimen that happens
every day in the morning foraging
one of the things that we're really
focused on is invasive species what if
we start focusing on ingredients that
nobody else wants to eat that are
abundant and even destructive of the
environment and by pulling them out of
the environment will help rebalance that
habitat
this is wild lettuce
and we're going to serve them with bug
holes in them it's like swiss cheese
that means that they're they're healthy
to eat and that they're pesticide
herbicide free
here's a big one
really can't hesitate have to be fully
committed to catch him see if i am
gotcha you're a lot stronger than you
think he's really pushing off my hand
yeah we're set to go let's rock and roll
[Music]
great
these snails from europe they're called
european snails
came over
stuck on ships
i feel like you're like a big kid just
crawling around looking under rocks
when i'm collecting it's always
incredibly exciting it's very thrilling
for me
well all right
but when i'm trying to figure out new
ways of working with an ingredient that
i've never worked with before or an
ingredient that actually grosses me out
i like the fact that i'm forcing myself
to
confront my own prejudices
today we went foraging for dandelion
amaranth
wild lettuce mugwort
butterbur
grasshopper invasive european snails a
whole bunch of asian shore crabs and
guacama seaweed and gracileera seaweed
[Music]
are you gonna be mad if we show the
whole world that you can make gourmet
sushi just using stuff in your backyard
that's what we want the whole world to
do or consider doing or think about
doing and not only that this isn't an
original idea people have been doing
this for tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of years way before before me
is and it's delicious and it's
absolutely delicious and nutritious
and great for the environment
[Music]
you